did you feel like a lot of the Kanye
stuff like did they did you have people
asking you about it oh yeah I think it
was probably miss miss uh labeled what
do you think is going on with Kanye
I don't think he's happy with his agents
he's saying legitimately he's saying the
same [ __ ] that I've said for years you
call agents you're Jews I'm just calling
the Jews there's a lot of Jews in there
so it's a colloquial you know right my
literal agent is not Jewish but he's one
of my Jews
and when he goes I'm going def Con on
the Jews he means he's going to fire his
agents he's just saying it he's an
artist he said he's not just gonna say
I'm going to fire my agents that's not
fun I wish you'd do it through song
that's where he excels oh you know but
but like they're like these anti-semitic
statements like guys he doesn't they
write a narrative and then they go like
that narrative can't be wrong so let's
jump off from there I'm like I think
you're jumping off ground might be wrong
you know
it's oh he's Theo's wearing a purple
shirt so he's gay
um so as a gay man sitting here he has
to do this and I'm like wait you know I
not be right about the Gay Part can we
re-examine like it's a narrative it's
already set right and so I just don't
think he's that and then you're pushing
him deeper and deeper into like
defending himself you're pushing him to
be anti-semitic he might have had one
thought here that's a little off and now
you're making who's coming on who's
coming down on him the [ __ ] Jews are
coming down on them so now you're the
oppressor
uh I don't I just don't think it's all
that I think Kyrie Irving too is like I
saw a [ __ ] documentary yeah we've all
been there yeah he saw a flat Earth
documentary too and he liked that one
dude I'll tell you this the flat I'll
tell you how I even learned about Flat
Earth I'm at a pizza spot Palm Springs
two black dudes roll up on me they say
do you think that that pizza is round or
flat that's what they said interesting
it's both right and next thing you know
for one hour I'm sitting in an Italian
spot listening to Two Brothers tell me
about Flat Earth I'd love to hear that
here's my advice to everybody when you
meet a crazy person do not argue with
them yeah you've gained nothing you will
not change their opinion and you will
have lost the chance to hear their whole
crazy argument you meet a q Anon person
you go you're making some good points
what else you got just do your research
you won't get access like that that's a
good point you know if you get [ __ ]
Mike Shanahan going like uh can tell you
about some place like oh no those plays
don't work no just go okay I'm you're
listening just listen yeah so yeah by
the way literally every person I know
maybe outside Joe Rogan
cannot prove to you that the Earth is
round
I think it's round but I I can't tell
you what I would not be shocked if it
wasn't yeah I'd be like
I would not be shocked dude yeah who the
[ __ ] was Galileo
I don't even have [ __ ] Spotify that
was one thing that I thought was
interesting that Kanye said was about
like history like the people like
whoever owns the were or controls the
world history writes the history yeah
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one